[Music]
dang
cool whip should hit him up dog cause he
got that
whip look at the cortez's welcome to
whip mississippi dawg
oh he's living oh [ __ ] oh that's cool
right dang bro
good for him man yeah they're coming out
with an ice cream too for him at ben and
jerry's oh they really yeah
chocolato vato
is the flavored hug and i'm gonna i'm
gonna get a gallon bruh yeah yeah you
know
dude i'm gonna have it before i drive by
shooting son i'm ready to wash it down
with some quartz there he is
what up what's up big dog what up what's
up playboy
how are you chillin man how you doing
good good to see you today man how you
feeling
vibing out like mother you know what i
mean
[Laughter]
bro so straight up you have so many
videos like um
is it amazing that obviously you know
you have the the
the skateboard ocean spray video you
know really kind of put you on a lot of
people's maps
but were you shocked that it took so
many videos for you to kind of like
catch some fire because man when you
look back through your catalog
so much of it is so uh just good energy
entertaining what were your thoughts on
some of that
i don't know i feel blessed that you
guys are even going through my page you
know what i mean but yeah
it's i don't know you know i mean it's
it was just
fun you know what i mean like i said i
was taking time out of my breaks at work
just to do videos just to
pass time and it made me feel good and
it was good exercise it was giving me
it's cool man like i said i was just
doing it out of fun you know what i mean
just to make everybody happy i'd be
getting comments saying that they
enjoyed it you know
some people would be like yo i've been
crying three days or three hours and i
looked at your video make me laugh you
know
it's cool man oh insane you know i just
like i said i i love it you know what i
mean
and what what were you doing for work
where you're taking a break shooting
these videos
every time on break i would go out i
work at a potato warehouse and i don't
fall as idaho
oh no idaho and potatoes goes hand in
hand
so yeah i just go on my breaks you know
and then i do a video here and there
well
i was doing them during work sometimes
before this
and then i i did get the office pulling
and you know talk
they'll talk it over with the boss you
need to not do videos while we're
working this and that
do it on your breaks do whatever dancing
is okay as long as you're not on the
machinery and you're good
you tell them what's up now what's up
now man
what's up now boss man you're cool
you're cool i quit i just called my
breaks and just get my boogie on you
know what i mean and
just like i said enjoy my life go back
in go back to work post it come back out
see how many views
if it didn't do good if not i just try
to top my next one you know and
yeah he wasn't ever trying to talk you
know i just go out and just do
a song or a dance that reminded me of
the old times and then
yeah just bring me back are you are you
still working there
yeah they they left me an open door they
told me basically
you can go out and figure this out
figure out what's going on you know
because i
got a manager out of left field you know
and
she's been booking me interviews and
everything getting my face out there and
trying to set a vibe to where i can try
to get some you know incoming set of
donations from this you know what i mean
and
yeah are you amazed at how many people
uh kind of can relate to your energy or
what do you
what do you think it is that makes you
so relatable to people
it's like you said it's got to be the
energy the vibe you know i mean cloud9
status all the time you know you know
that's where i'm at you know
try not to get a care in the world you
know i mean life's way too short to be
worrying about anything you know
like that you know i mean besides death
you know what i mean in my eyes
yeah and i think you're right yeah i
think you're perfect timing too because
the world right now is pretty crazy man
it's pretty dark everybody's locked down
yeah everybody's trying to catch a wave
right now and it's i think that was
probably the thing it just felt like you
were on this wave that a lot of people
have been trying to catch
uh exactly the positive way yeah just
that moment
um and so you where you live over there
like what are your neighbors thinking
and [ __ ] like were they like what the
hell is going on like what was like
what was the immediate community i'm
talking the next door neighbors what's
their vibe
when they see when they seen the cars
and all that i guess i don't know
when they brought the truck or whatever
that they got from ocean spray
yeah it was insane like i said i went
outside and they were out there with
their
with their cameras too filming and
everything some neighbors that didn't
say hi you know
were waving you know and yeah when
everybody's asking for a ride
yeah they were driving by and then they
were like hong kong
yeah i'm your son
[Laughter]
now what about this we were you brendan
and i had a discussion if i'm drink if
i'm drinking ocean
spray usually for me i'm recovering from
the night before
from partying too hard brendan said he's
drinking it if he's mixing it with vodka
did you have uh
what was what was where were you where
were you at neither or you know what i
mean i did get just out of pleasure you
know
like i said i'm 420 all the way you know
what i mean 7-1
so to me it's all about the flavor and
everything you know what i mean the best
munchies to me is fruit you know what i
mean
and that's the next best thing if i
ain't got an apple or anything you know
are you married kids interesting i have
a lady that hopefully you know something
in the works there you know because i
was playing it before all this and
to me she's always been the one you know
so yeah i do have a lady
good three-year-old myself and soon
these steps on you know oh good for you
man
gang man and so are you and we we're all
guests and we got a pretty mixed group
in here i mean some of us are filipino
and some of us are white
some of us don't know who our dad is in
here but
we wanted what ethnicity are you tell us
a little bit about your background man
i'm native mexican you know i get the
mexican side from my dad he's a black
foot from blackfoot idaho full blooded
mexican
i get the native side from my mom's side
she's full-blooded northern arapaho you
know represent
yeah damn damn wow dude that's crazy
you're like the most popular native
american
since i'm trying to think of who man
yeah maybe geronimo dawg
yeah you're up there man that's cool
that's got to be inspiring i bet for a
lot of that whole community like all of
it you know what i'm saying like when
you think about it i hope you know
yeah doing the damn thing you're the
north star let's you get that we see
that feather tattoo in the videos man
oh yeah yeah that's done
so what uh when you think of like
obviously you know there's a lot of like
new popularity and that sort of thing
um how do you are you worried about like
ego and like how to manage it and stuff
like that like what are some things that
you're kind of thinking
on on that i don't know dude you know
what i mean i feel the same you know i
was at
doing an interview with a local radio
station today and people are driving by
honking you know
i was just giving them the wave and
everything i don't
you know i ain't thinking nothing too
big on this you know i ain't nobody
special you know still
like i said i'm just sparkling the
world's eye right now you know that's
gonna dim out
sooner or later you know but as soon as
somebody catches another wave like you
said something else to vibe on that's
what's up you know and i'm just here to
live it up you know i bet those dms are
juicy right now
you got a lady them idaho potato lovers
that they're dealing
with juicy
[Laughter]
but look at hey it's a dirty temptation
bro tell you that dude
it's a dirty temptation that's preached
brother preach
we both fall in love and [ __ ] though you
know oh yeah yeah
that's a beautiful spot to be um
i'm trying to think i mean i feel like
there's so many possibilities for you to
like
you know to find an avenue to continue
to entertain people if you want
you know like hosting it could be dance
contests could be stuff on the street
where you're just
coming up on just regular people like
yourself and just you know interacting
with them i mean
i think there's i mean oh yeah i i
actually have a weed string coming out
in california
brother also that's what i'm talking
about if ellen was in such an [ __ ]
right now i'm sure you'd be on that show
dancing tomorrow but i don't know what's
going on though
about it it's always open you know what
i mean if she's ever sees this or
anything you know
open invite you know let me let me come
in oh you'll be on there in the next two
weeks
i would guarantee it i would guarantee
dude i might relapse on that stream bro
if that strains any good y'all gonna
have to let me know i might come out the
freaking dope casket
that's what i'm saying man um well man
we appreciate your time so much and uh
and yeah i just yeah i just wish the
best for you man it seemed like
you know your whole energy is really
great and i mean it even makes our room
feel better this morning any other
questions
and i'll say this too but like i'm not
on social media a lot
and so when they said uh you know we got
dog face come in i was like who's that
and they showed me the video and i i'll
be honest i was like i don't get it what
is it
but now that we're talking you're such a
positive dude man that's what this is
you're such a positive person man i'm a
fan
i'm a fan that's what's up man yeah i
can catch another one you know what i
mean
you're a soldier are your kids on ig2 or
your daughters on ig are they young or
of course you know what i mean of course
they got ig they got snapchat they got
all the work you know what i mean
so they must be vi they must be like
holy [ __ ] that's
cool that's cool that's tom cruise
his messages and whatnot you know what i
mean yeah they're like man i want to be
his i want to be his uh son-in-law hey
what what what car
did uh ocean spray give you it was a
nissan
it was it's just beautiful man there's a
frontier
oh that's cool it's a dope truck yeah
because i saw when you were driving i
could see like the hand the one of the
bars on the top through the kind of
sunroof a little bit so i was thinking
yeah it looked like a suv
or something it was awesome man shouts
out to ron sayer if i don't follow
shouts out to
you know what i mean ocean spray it's
it's just it's just amazing dude
it had the miles on it didn't even have
triple digits
my car who had you know
yeah your car had every mile on it
tell me about it and where can peop can
people purchase that shirt you're
rocking because i know we've purchased
it i got different designs as well it's
not just this one you know i mean i feel
a little
weird walking my mug on here you know
okay
you're on the right show for we we have
half of our stuff we wearing here is our
own mug
so i'm wearing another grown man i don't
care
the hustle is real you know and yeah so
like i said it's in my bio
in my ig at dog phase 208
it's inside my tick tock 420 dog phase
208 you know it's all in my bio
gang man we're going to order something
for our group man and uh
yeah thanks for your time dude i feel
like your time is like the most precious
time right now so we're grateful for it
to me you know what i mean thank you
guys for taking the time yeah keep
killing it brother we wish you the best
man
continued success what do you got
cooking up with fleetwood mac
i i i know you guys been communicating i
haven't heard nothing all i heard was
or when mick fleetwood went out and
actually made his own tick tock account
and mcflywood actually went out and did
his own video of mine you know what i
mean
it was crazy then we actually had a
little comment uh
interaction on tick tock and that's
about as far as it went but
there was good words that he said you
know and it's just a blessing you know
wow that's
crazy man are you amazed like because
now that song has become the number one
song in america again
right that's crazy that's what i keep
hearing and then yeah i just keep
getting different
messages from everybody from you know my
mamas my aunties everybody
this is number one now this number
whatever it's going all the way up and
then now it's number one so yeah
that's that's badass you know what i
mean should we incarnate something like
that
yeah it's a beautiful song you know what
i mean yeah
you know what i mean yeah it's awesome
yeah it's almost amazing how so many
great songs kind of dis
or go by the wayside when if you could
just reintroduce them in a unique way
that people would fall in love with them
again
exactly it just takes time you know yeah
that's cool man
yeah man thank you so much brother we
appreciate your time i'm a fan brother
you won me over
oh wait i got one more question for dog
face you still there
yeah what's up why they call you dog
face yeah what's his real name
okay basically my name is nathan grown
up
nobody wants to call me nathan because
that's dumb you know so they call me
nate so then yeah
nate dogs growing up you know in the 90s
so they call me nate dog
nate dog died you know he's a living
legend i told everybody don't call me
dog no more basically so they shortened
it to dog and then
calling me dog around people you know
just people looking at me so i just kind
of embraced i started barking at people
my family and friends were like you know
what we're going to stop calling him dog
because he started taking a little too
far now
i went and did my ig and then i was
thinking one name to put putting nate
nate dog
all that data that nothing was coming up
so then i was like man everybody always
says dog
this dog that i must have a dog face you
know so there it is dog face to a weight
and then you have 4 20 is what i do dog
face is the name
i love it brother i mean oh yeah that's
all i needed i'm good
all right be good
that's awesome that was awesome yeah i
told you going in i was like i don't get
it man
you know what i get it